hey guys it's Jenna here I'm not feeling
my 100% I had a slight fever yesterday
and also a sort and flu but you know
what I'm really excited to be sharing
with you another of my favorite recipe
so let me just start by saying eggs are
amazing how many of you started date by
having eggs
whenever I have eggs for breakfast I
always notice that I am fuller for much
longer and there is no need for my
mid-morning snack eggs are a great
source of inexpensive high quality
protein so today I want to be sharing
with you my favorite egg recipes which I
like to make over the weekend for my
family and friends they are healthy
fresh very delicious and very easy to
put together so to start off let's give
the traditional quiche a twist
instead of using pastry we want to solve
that with bell pepper cups and fill them
up with the classic mix of cheese eggs
leeks and also mushroom what you'll need
are three large eggs two large bell
peppers half a cup of mushroom sliced
cut a cup of leeks thinly sliced about 8
to 10 cherry tomatoes cut a cup of any
milk of your choice
cut a cup of any cheese grated 1 TSP of
olive oil and a pinch of salt and pepper
preheat the oven to 180 degrees Celsius
or 350 degrees Fahrenheit so let's start
by prepping the bell peppers slice each
of them into halves and remove the seeds
set aside heat olive oil over medium
heat then add leeks and saute very
quickly for about 1 to 2 minutes until
soft then stir in the mushrooms and
continue to saute for another 2 to 3
minutes until mushrooms are slightly
tender remove from heat and set aside in
a bowl add
the eggs milk and salt and pepper give
it a good mix set aside line a baking
tray with parchment paper and place the
bell peppers fill the cups generously
with the fillings and also cherry
tomatoes then pour about a quarter cup
of the egg mixture into each bell pepper
cap if at all the bell pepper isn't
sitting well what you can do is use a
little bit of aluminum foil to hold it
in place
finally top it up with grated cheese and
bake in the oven for 20 to 25 minutes
and your eggs are cooked through and
golden brown serve hot this pepper
quiche
are absolutely delicious they are so
fluffy low in color and packed with
high-quality protein and also vegetables
so bring some color to the table and
make this quiche in pepper cups another
of my favorite dish is kiss ideas but it
is not always the healthiest option
especially if it's loaded with lots of
cheese and it can be very high in
calories so instead of making the
traditional quesadillas let's make it
open-faced which means lower calorie per
slice we want to top it out with lots of
vegetables and only sprinkle with a
light amount of cheese so for each
quesadilla when you'll need are one
medium whole grain tortilla 2x one cup
of fresh baby spinach quarter cup of
onions diced cortico of bell pepper
diced quarter cup of any cheese grated
about two tablespoons of black olives
sliced one teaspoon of olive oil half a
teaspoon of cayenne pepper and salt and
pepper to taste
preheat the oven to 180 degrees Celsius
or 350 degrees Fahrenheit so let's start
by prepping the eggs break and scramble
the eggs in a small bowl season with
cayenne pepper and salt and pepper set
aside hits olive oil over medium low
heat stir fry the onions and bell pepper
for one to two minutes until fragrant
then add the spinach and cook for
another one to two minutes until wilted
pour in the eggs and cook very quickly
until the eggs are just set only for
about 1 minutes we don't want to
overcook as the eggs will finish cooking
in the oven so remove from heat and set
aside line a baking tray with parchment
paper and place one tortilla top it up
with the scrambled egg mixture some
olives and sprinkle with cheese then
place in the oven and cook very quickly
just for 5 to 6 minutes until cheese is
melted and transfer the quesadilla to a
cutting board to cool down for a couple
of minutes and slice into 6 equal
portions serve warm this is such a great
and light dish to be shared it is
crunchy crispy and cheesy at the same
time it is just like a thin crust pizza
and each slice is under 100 calories the
best part is you can choose to top it up
with any toppings of your choice you can
even serve it as a starter or even as a
finger food so you got to try it and
finally why not give the ordinary egg
and toast a quick make over I tend to
have egg and toast very regularly for my
breakfast and sometimes it is nice to
put in a little bit more effort to make
breakfast and look pretty it is pleasing
to the eyes it will be pleasing to the
tummy and I am sure your family and kids
will love it so to make egg in a basket
you only need 2 thick slices of whole
grain bread 2 eggs 1 TSP of olive oil a
pinch of salt and pepper and also a
large cookie cutter break each egg into
a small bowl set aside then use the
cookie cutter cut out the center of each
bread slice in a non-stick pan hits
olive oil over medium low heat we want
to toast the bread slices and cut outs
on one side until golden brown then turn
the bread pieces over and gently pour
each egg into the center of each bread
slice
the pan and allow the eggs to cook
slowly for four to five minutes until
the whites are completely set and the
yolks begin to thicken but are in hot
then season with salt and pepper and
serve immediately with the cut outs
I just love to slice into the runny yolk
don't you this dish is packed with both
carbs and protein to sustain your energy
level it also makes a great post-workout
snack I love pretty looking breakfasts
because it puts a smile on my face
so guys start your morning by having a
bigger and more satisfying breakfast so
that you won't have the urge to snack as
often throughout the day it will help to
manage your appetite which also helps to
maintain a healthy weight long term so
this recipes are also great for lunch or
dinner so make them share the recipes
with your friends let me know which is
your favorite in the comments below and
don't forget to snap pictures of your
creation and share them with me on
Facebook or Instagram all the best so if
you want to become a certified personal
trainer just like me you can do so by
signing up to the National Academy of
Sports Medicine & ASM online personal
training costs they are currently
offering a 14-day free trial and you'll
get to learn more about nutrition
creating a personalized fitness program
and also skills to understand your
clients so be sure to click on the link
in my description box to get more
information and share this